this notion that fear is a great
motivator is actually true the problem
is it's not sustainable you may get what
you want in the short term but deep down
all those people hate you and if
they hate you they'll steal from you
they'll backstab you they'll leave you
and how can you blame them you
used fear to motivate them you're the
worst how many people right now are in a
corporate or business environment where
the ultimate boss strives fear and
you're trying to be the middle person to
balance it to protect them but you're
eating the from the boss stand the
up if you're one of these people
right now please don't me don't
be scared stand up
every one of those people need to quit
their job
now easy for me to say all they all see
on this stage what I probably do
first is have one real kind Candor
conversation hey boss I've been here for
three years two years six months nine
years this is the real situation you're
scaring people I'm trying to make it but
it's wearing on me it's not sustainable
it's not my business are you capable of
adjusting to this but you have to have
one conversation and then see if it does
anything